what is going on with the British
economy the global economy Etc what
should people know well the world has
not actually managed to get out of
second gear since lockdown the long kind
of lingering taale of the pandemic is
still with us China is not at the moment
anyway the global growth locomotive that
it has been for most of the last two or
even three decades people don't like to
hear it but UK exports to the EU you
right have never been higher at least we
can now have a discussion and raise
issues about Net Zero not about the
ultimate direction of travel but the
speed and the cost and the distribution
of those costs we have to have those
discussions because if we don't have
those discussions this isn't a democracy
the war in Ukraine has accelerated and
accentuated a process that was already
happening a process that's shifting
power away from the west and towards the
east because we don't like to talk about
it very much in the west because it's
awkward and it has a sense of the end of
history about it but that doesn't mean
it's not
[Music]
true hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine
kissen and this is a show for you if you
want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our terrific and
returning guest today is in a Economist
writer and broadcaster leam helan
welcome back for the third time it's
great to have you back good to be with
you guys and uh we always invite you on
whenever we want an update on what's
actually going on we talk a lot about
culture on the show and politics but you
are someone who's got real substance and
real economic uh you know strong
background in analysis so uh let's get
straight into it what is going on with
the British economy the global economy
Etc what should people know well the
world has not actually managed to get
out of second gear since lockdown the
long kind of lingering tail of the
pandemic is still with us the UK economy
is just about growing avoiding recession
Germany Europe's biggest economy is in
recession the US is doing okay um but
China which has been the engine of
global growth the locomotive if you like
for at least the last 20 years
contributing a lot more to the global
economy in terms of raw numbers and GDP
than the US even China has stalled now
that doesn't mean China's going into
reverse it doesn't even mean it's
growing at 1 or 2% it means instead of
growing at 8 9 10% as it has been from
basically you know 1980 all the way
through to a few years ago China's now
growing at four or 5% and it's not just
that China's growing quite slowly which
means there's less growth elsewhere it's
also the Chinese property sector the
Chinese Shadow banking sector it's now
big enough systemic enough ugly enough
if you like that it could cause another
kind of layman moment there's a lot of
people in the market there's a lot of
research notes going around saying
things along the lines of these big
Chinese property conglomerates that have
been massively um bloated over many
years a huge amount of the country's
wealth is in residential property it's
very difficult for middle-class Chinese
people to save any other way um sounds
familiar to be honest these big property
companies could they be on the verge of
collapse could there be some kind of
systemic layman style um moment uh
coming out of China and that's a big
fear that in recent months has been
stalking Global markets and the broader
global economy and I don't want to jump
in because there's lots more for you to
cover in terms of everything that's
going on but on this particular issue if
that were to happen you say layman style
event would it have a global impact of
that sort of significance if of course
it were China's the second biggest
economy in the world it's the biggest
economy in the world on some definitions
on what we call a purchasing power
parity basis when you adjust for
currencies um but it's it is it is a big
economy but I don't actually think it's
going to happen I think this is sort of
overdone I think a lot of people in the
markets are putting scare stories out
there as they always do when they want
to get the FED to stop raising rates or
even to start cutting rates the main
reason I think that is because unlike
layman in the runup to layman in 2008
you had people buying houses with sort
of 5% deposits no no deposits you know
negative deposits where the mortgage
company actually gives you money for
furniture and stuff when you buy a house
but in China for years and years and
years the rules have been very strict
certainly in the big cities you need a
30 40 50% deposit so there's a lot less
chance of these big companies going into
negative equity of ordinary people going
into NE Equity but look be in no doubt
this is a major moment in the evolution
the astonishing evolution of the Chinese
economy there is a scare over the
property Market but I for one don't
think we're going to see a big systemic
Lurch coming out of the Chinese property
Market I think we're much more likely to
see a big systemic Lurch by the way on
Western markets government debt markets
as we unwind QE and that's a big sort of
theme in my thinking at the moment well
we'll talk about the the Western world
are the Emerging Markets now and the
Emerging Markets are the West well we'll
talk about that in France before before
you take over I just want to finish with
China because there's a guy we've had on
called Peter zahan I don't know if
you're familiar with him whose Central
argument is China is in a demographic
collapse this is why you're starting to
see everything and it's just that's
going to continue going to get worse Etc
do you do you buy that argument yeah I
mean look that's been going around the
markets for years will China get rich
before it gets old right uh and the
question is will China get to a sort of
GDP per head a purchasing power per head
that can sustain the economy and get it
out of what we call the middle- inome
Trap that Emerging Markets go through as
they become Advanced industrialized
economies I think China can do that I
think China's got tremendous Firepower I
think China um is you know through its
closeness uh with the other Emerging
Markets since the war in Ukraine we've
seen a massive consolidation of the
brick concept it's very fashionable to
dismiss that as a nonsense no don't
dismiss it as a nonsense a very very
important grouping just like people
dismiss OPEC sometimes
as a nonsense it shows that they don't
actually know anything about geopolitics
so I I don't see China as the main
source of global systemic danger in the
world at the moment though absolutely
China is not at the moment anyway the
global growth locomotive that it has
been for most of the last two or even
three decades what about India because
they're doing supremely well aren't they
India are doing well obviously the
world's biggest democracy India is doing
very very nicely out the war in Ukraine
thank you it's importing a lot of
Russian oil and then turning it around
refining it re-exporting it as Indian
oil making a lot of money I think though
there are the these are very big
countries and there attentions you know
you'll know Constantine about the close
relations between Russia and India over
many years India was part of the
non-aligned group in the in the 60s you
know when I lived in Russia constantly
kept coming across very sophisticated
Indian people who spoke great Russian
they'd been there for for a generation
they'd often been to the top Russian
universities of obviously Russia sells
India most of its arms so there's a
closeness there but there's also a
tension because India of all the bricks
is probably the one that's closest to
the West certainly closest to America
politically given the massive Indian
diaspora in America and of course
there's tensions between China and India
you know China and India are technically
at War over parts of the Himalayas uh
literally troops standing off against
each other so this bricks conglomerate
is it's not entirely plain sailing it
doesn't make complete coherent sense but
you know NATO doesn't make complete
coherent sense the Allies in the first
and second world war didn't make
complete coherent sense but they were
very very powerful forces in the Affairs
of men so I do think India is pretty
soon going to overtake China officially
as the most populous country in the
world and of course despite all the
bureaucracy it is a more attractive
place to invest for the West it's got
it's it I wouldn't call it open uh but
it's a lot less closed than China and I
think culturally it's a lot more attuned
to the west and I think very very
importantly without mentioning the b
word brexit oh I just did if we if the
UK right manages to sign a trade deal
with India that will be noticed not just
here in the UK that will be noticed
around the world because India does not
sign trade deals very very often and if
it manages at the height of this kind of
brick Mania when it's you know not not
on the west side in the war in Ukraine
very much riding two horses very much
realigning itself with the fast growing
economies of the East as it must finally
getting out from under the sort of
colonial yoke of Europe and the Brits in
particular if despite all that
Modi green lights uh comprehensive trade
deal with the UK that would be a major
moment not just for the British economy
not just for the debate on brexit
because of course you couldn't do that
within the EU that would be a big moment
geopolitically for the world cuz it
would say to the world India is open for
business and Liam let's talk a little
bit about brexit because things are not
good economically here to put it mildly
and there's a lot of people in certain
Publications and news stations screaming
and shouting and saying this is the
fault of brexit what do you expect we've
now left the Customs Union we've done
all of these things we're now an
economic freeall this is your fault or
is the picture somewhat more complex
than that I'd say it's a bit more
complex for for one thing we're not in
economic freefall the UK econom is
growing it's very much in the middle of
the pack when it comes to the G7 um both
in terms of How It's grown since 2016
and how it's grown since the end of the
pandemic Germany is in recession Germany
was in the EU last time I checked um and
people don't like to hear it but UK
exports to the EU right have never been
higher all you know thanks Anna sub
saying on question time our exports to
Europe she literally said will go
absolutely almost to
zero completely incoherent but she was
basically saying we wouldn't export to
the EU now utter rubbish we we have
never exported more in value terms to
the EU than we currently are now part of
that is because America is um shipping
huge amounts of liquified natural gas
across the Atlantic America's become
since the war in Ukraine by the way the
largest exporter of LG in the world it's
good business they're making a lot of
money and as the West has as Western
Europe has weaned itself off Russian oil
and gas in particular America has filled
that Gap and a lot of that LNG comes
through British LNG terminals not least
at Milford Haven and then we reexport a
lot of that to Mainland Europe but be
that as it may there are many other
categories under which exports to Europe
are actually doing really well and the
UK has just overtaken France to become
the biggest manufacturer in the world so
you know the the the the so-call
journalists who say we don't make
anything everything's crap the UK's in
in in economic freefall you know all
World warned us about these people
there's a whole class of people in
Britain and they will always diss their
country and it's and you know I when
allwell was writing you know I wasn't
even British I was you my people were
picking spuds in the west of Island
right living in stone huts and yet I
would say that there there's an awful
lot of ingratitude in the UK towards the
UK particularly among families who know
that in their past a few Generations
back they were the nasty Colonial
Masters they're the people who you know
whose wealth is built off the back of
that kind of behavior and so a lot of
them make it into the into the top of
the mainstream media it's not a
meritocracy my business and then they
get there and they think they have to
diss the country in order to keep their
conscience at Bay well a lot of ordinary
hardworking people the alarm clock
classes of Britain the people who make
things actually happen and work the
people that drive our economy forward
they actually quite like the UK whether
they were born here whether they came
here you know and as I have the sort of
gratitude of of of an immigrant if you
like when my father arrived here uh from
the west of Ireland in the 1950s England
was a properly racist country and it was
no blacks no dogs and no Irish and we
got the photos to prove it so let's not
deny it we're a world away from that now
and of course there's still bad stuff
going on of course there are nasty
people out there but I actually think
the UK for all the the negative
publicity we get um economically we're
doing okay and I think in terms of
integration and multiculturalism we're
doing okay people will say I'm being
really complacent I'm not I just don't
think it's nearly as bad as certain
broadcasters always tell us that it is
well as you say there are a lot of
people whose whole world view is
invested in that being true and so they
they spread that idea but coming back
back to economics Lim you've mentioned
we've talked about one controversial
word brexit there is another thing that
you've mentioned about four or five
times already which is of course the war
in Ukraine we don't want to relitigate
the whole conflict and everything but uh
what I'd be interested to know is what
you think are some of the key impacts of
that conflict on the world economy on
the rebalancing and restructuring of the
world uh and for people here at home
what has been the impact and what will
be the impact of the war in Ukraine well
once the war in Ukraine began in Earnest
because of course there was a sort of
lowlevel War as you and I discussed a
lot constin from from Medan onwards from
2014 onwards there's lots of bombing
going on in in danet and Lans and so on
but once Russia actually invaded in
February 2022 I think a lot of the world
suddenly realized uh what's obvious to
those of us who've lived and worked in
the region a lot that you know these
countries produce a lot of food and they
you know Ukraine isn't the Bread Basket
of Europe for no reason you know the're
historic import of of ports like Odessa
the grain funnel of the former Soviet
Union and so a lot of people have have
realized that if you blockade Russia if
Russian ships blockade Ukrainian ports
then food prices are going to spike and
that's what happened and you've got
countries in North Africa Around the
Horn of Africa who are very very heavily
dependent on Russian and Ukrainian grain
but also here in the UK you know all
those staple foods that come out of that
part of the world so we've certainly
seen a food price uh Spike but we've
seen a spike in inflation more generally
and you can't attribute it solely to the
war in Ukraine though I know the bank of
England likes to because even in January
2022 when almost no one thought Putin
was going to invade including most of
the people around him inflation in the
UK was already at a 30-year high it was
already at a 30-year High the war in
Ukraine knocked inflation up to a 40y
year high and we're still living with
the implications of that and it may get
worse at the moment of course in the UK
the latest numbers inflation's come down
to 6.7% in August from 6.8% in July and
that means that the bank of England
after these Falls has been able to keep
interest rates where they are for now at
five and a quarter perc and the UK is in
a similar Pace to to the Federal Reserve
in America European Central Bank in the
Euro Zone you know there may be one or
two more rate Rises to come but for the
most part we think we've got our arms
mostly around inflation and possibly we
H have but it may be that there's
another twist this autumnn this is my
concern last autumn and winter was
relatively mild that meant we were able
to spend less money than we thought we
were going to spend subsidizing
households and firms energy bills we
still spent tens of billions of pounds
but it was less than we thought we were
going to spend America of course hasn't
got that energy problem because it's
been fracking that's why uh retail
electricity prices in America are a
third of what they are in the UK the UK
is bit the most expensive in Europe
partly because of the way we we do
marginal cost pricing and use Renewables
you can ask me about that in another
question if you like but for now at
least we've got you know still got quite
High Energy prices but an expectation
that they're going to keep coming down
right but but but if this war in Ukraine
continues and it's probably going to
continue because why would Putin want to
stop it until he knows what's happening
in the white house right so that's all
the way through to November 24 so I
think it's going to go on until then but
if he decides to turn the screw this
autumn and winter what's emerged is an
axis that no one in the west wants to
talk about and that is the Riad Moscow
axis the Saudis of course the absolutely
pivotal us Ally after the second world
war you know Security in return for the
black stuff that's now breaking down
because oil has spiked enormously over
the last few months no one again wants
to talk about we we've gone from just
over 70 bucks a bar
in June to 95 plus bucks a barrel now
and that's you know 35% increase that's
huge in August we saw the sharpest spike
in the UK in petrol and diesel prices on
the for court that we've seen in 23
years in percentage terms and Riad and
Moscow are now working together look
OPEC controls a half of all Global oil
production the O the exporters cartel
and 4 of all known oil reserves right if
you had in Russia not an OPEC member but
very much working with OPEC in this
grouping called OPEC plus then OPEC plus
controls 2third of all Global Production
and 90% of all reserves right and the
reason oil is high now isn't because the
global economy is growing fast and so
people are demanding more oil which bids
the price up because as we have
established the global economy is not
really out of second gear post lockdown
right yet still oil is surging because
the Saudis and the Russians are
deliberately taking oil out of the
market now and have been for months and
we're not talking about it but it's
completely true ask any oil Trader the
only reason oil is pushing 100 bucks
it's probably going to hit 100 bucks is
because of OPEC and that is a
geopolitical wakeup call and that could
very easily complicate the West's
ability to finally escape from this cost
of living CR crisis which of course
would then have knock on effects in
terms of public support for the West's
entire approach to the war in Ukraine So
when you say they they're taking oil out
of the market for a Layman what does
that mean does it mean they're just not
releasing it they're keeping it yeah it
means instead of producing you know like
10 million barrels a day right the world
uses about 100 million barrels of oil a
day right instead of producing about 10
million barrels a day the Saudis will
say oh we produce nine for now and we
might go to eight cuz they can get as
much money because if the price goes up
they can make the same amount of money
selling less oil and is that the
motivation Liam or is there something
more Sinister going on in terms of they
are trying to flex their muscles
geopolitically as well look go back to
the yipo war right and opec's response
to that go back to the or in early 70s
go back to the O price shock after the
Iranian Revolution of
1979 OPEC is not a benign organization
right OPEC is there they say to
stabilize oil prices no OPEC is there to
maximize the revenue for its members and
that will often mean pumping less oil
than the world needs in order to push
the price up to make more money from
selling less oil and within that that is
obviously a hugely powerful tool and
Saudi is the lynchpin of that but you've
also got other very very powerful
economies you youve got the Iraqis in
there you got the Mexicans you got the
Venezuelans you got the Iranians you got
the Nigerians these are powerful players
right and it's not just about money it's
also about control and flex geopolitical
muscles because a lot of people within
OPEC and the countries they represent
they don't they don't look at the world
the way we in the west look at the world
they have a different world view they
have a different history they have a
different understanding of Western
hegemony and its legitimacy you know in
this country in this part of the world
we take it for granted but a lot of
people don't take it for granted and I'm
sure like like you know like myself
you've had many many convers ation both
of you with people from you know other
big economies that aren't Western
economies and very highly educated very
clever people think completely different
things to what you're going to read in
your Economist or your ft or your
Telegraph for that matter and that
realization is now coming to pass you
know this bricks grouping it isn't just
about Summits and seminars you know
they're building their own ratings
agencies they're bu building their own
payment clearance system they're
building their own version of Swift
which is the kind of financial Plumbing
of the world controlled by the US which
America can turn on and off to impose
sanctions on other countries and they
often do well a lot of these big
economies are pushing back these
economies now have the line share of
hard currency reserves in the world of
gold they certainly have the line share
of the rare earth that we need if this
electric vehicle Revolution is ever
going to properly get off the ground so
an OPEC is part of that this bricks and
OPEC are now overlapping to challenge
sort of G7 NATO that process was
happening anyway through a natural um
growth uh you know as they get more of
the population as they get a bigger
share of the world economy you know the
bricks combined now are bigger than the
G7 that's been the case for a number of
years but the war in the war in Ukraine
has accelerated and accentuated a
process that was already happening a
process that's shifting power away from
the west and towards the east and I'm
not saying this cuz I'm some kind of
anti-western person on the contrary I'm
just trying to be realistic about what's
happening and political analysts and
Investors Business Leaders you know any
aware citizen sitting in the west needs
to understand that this is happening
because we don't like to talk about it
very much in the west because it's
awkward and it has a sense of the end of
history about it but that doesn't mean
it's not true Liam you've been you've
been talking about OPEC and bricks and
there'll be people who are not
economists who are not of with this can
you just break it down for us what these
two terms mean yeah and
also what is it they represent and what
is it that they want so they're separate
but they're a bit overlapping so OPEC is
the organization of petroleum exporting
countries it was it was founded in Rabat
in Morocco it was originally very much
an Arab organization and it really burst
onto the world stage in the early 70s
when you had the yamkipur War uh and in
response uh as to as they saw it Israeli
aggression the Arab countries basically
said right we are going to make life
really difficult for for the West
particularly for America that supports
Israel and you know talk to anybody in
America of a certain age and they'll
remember the huge gas cues it's when
American cars stopped being like massive
as they are in stari and Hut and started
to get small and Compact and Japanese
they went away from Gas Guzzlers towards
cars that were more cost effective in
terms of fuel so that's OPEC and OPEC
has had had had lulls when it's been
less powerful less coherent because it
relies on all the countries agreeing
that they're going to cut at the same
time otherwise you can get free rider
things happening where countries don't
cut but they benefit from the fact that
the price has gone up because others
have cut so that's OPEC and it has
become very fashionable in Western
Capitals in recent years to dismiss OPEC
as a spent Force the amount of sort of
oped I've seen in Posh Western
newspapers but you can't deny the
numbers and the numbers are as I've said
OPEC controls a huge share of both
production daily and Global reserves but
now what's new is you've got a proper
semiformal linkage between OPEC and that
other massive energy Giant in the world
Russia right um and that's based on the
relationship between Muhammad bin Salman
and Vladimir Putin which was forged by
the way in the Moscow World Cup it's no
no coincidence that the first match in
the Moscow World Cup was Saudi versus
Russia the host nation and there's an
incredible photo of Putin and Bin Selman
sitting next to each other watching that
match and they're literally sort of
hugging each other um so that's OPEC and
the bricks is something different but
related the bricks emerged um in the
early 2000s as a sort of informal
grouping it was originally a kind of an
investment idea you want to invest in
these big Emerging Markets because
that's where the growth is that's where
the global balance of power and
economics is Shifting that's where the
growing middle classes that's where uh
the money is going to be in the future
but since they were uh agglomerated in
that sense these five countries Brazil
Russia India China and more recently
South Africa have really worked at
coming up with coherent positions on
certain things and they've worked at
coordinating currency swaps between
their central banks as I said setting up
their own ratings agencies that aren't
dominated by the US and the UK setting
up their own um Payment Systems uh
there's talk about them set well they
are now I mean Chinese and the Russians
they settle their energy trade so this
is the biggest um one of the biggest
energy exporters in the world and one of
the biggest energy importers and they
settle their energy trades not in
dollars but in R&B and and rubles right
now now any student of economic history
will tell you KY that's amazing
because Petr currency status all oil
transactions are settled in dollars
right that is the ba Bedrock of
America's and the dollars Reserve
currency status and Reserve currency
status allows you uh to issue your own
currency and the rest of the world
treats it as a hard currency right so as
deal said of America's uh Reserve
currency status why are we all paying
the interest on Uncle Sam's debt it is
the exorbitant privilege of being the
world's Reserve currency it used to be
the Brits in the 19th and into the 20th
century the pound as good as gold it was
literally as good as gold that's where
the phrase comes from and then it became
America in the mid to late 1930s
Consolidated at Breton woods and
America's had Reserve currency status
and a lot of people are jealous of that
the Europeans were jealous of that
that's why they wanted to set up the
Euro The single currency but now the
Chinese the Indians the Russians are
jealous of that may jump in with a
Layman question how sustainable is this
because once you've got all these R&B
you're going to have to spend them on
something and they don't trade enough
with each other in that way do they
that's absolutely true and that's why
the push back argument is that so much
of China's wealth is in dollars why
would they want to undermine the dollar
and I would say yeah but these things
don't happen overnight you know you only
really know that the world's Reserve
currency has switched when you look back
in five years time and you think oh yeah
that was probably the moment but clearly
um the dollar is on the Wayne I mean the
dollar is going to be the probably the
main Reserve currency for the rest of my
life these are very long-term trends but
I do think there's a move now
particularly after quantitative easing
when Western central banks spat the
dummy and massively undermine their own
reputation for management by creating so
much you money on the Fly I do think
countries are now looking at different
ways of storing their currencies in
synthetic currencies in in crypto
currencies in agglomerated currencies
where you have a basket of currencies
and then you create a new currency out
of that and store your wealth in that
and these are the kind of things that
the brick leadership and the
intelligence here around this grouping
are exploring and it's impossible to
ignore them because what they're
actually doing really interesting work
that a lot of people in the west are
thinking of as well Liam I want to ask
you something because the undertone to
everything that we're talking about here
is essentially what Vladimir Putin has
been talking about which is the move
away from a mono unipolar World in which
America is dominant and absolutely in
control of everything and the West sort
of works with it to a multi-polar world
right that's that's the
underturned
because you mentioned already the fact
that we're debasing our currency on an
on a daily basis basically print a crap
ton of money irresponsibly in my opinion
saddle our own grandchildren with debts
so that we can spend money that we don't
have today right noding along to this
how much of it also this is less the
case in the US where they're still
producing energy but in this country
where we've got all these lunatics
running around shutting down traffic and
whatever screaming just stop oil when we
need to produce our own energy because
ultimately we're going to have to buy it
from the Saudis or from the Russians or
from the whoevers if we don't produce
ourselves I think part of it is
self-inflicted because in the west we've
we've all acquired what seem now to be
compulsory luxury views you know you
have to think certain things or you're a
bad person I mean the three of us
involved in this conversation and I'm
sure many trigonometry viewers and
listeners you know they have views that
upset other people at dinner parties but
that doesn't mean that they're wrong um
and I think the media has a lot of blame
to share here our media in the UK it's
meant to be a very vibrant media very
sophisticated media it is both those
things to a degree but it's suffering in
my view certainly in the mainstream from
an actual Ely chronic lack of diversity
now I don't mean that there aren't
enough women or brown people on the
screen uh there are lots more women and
lots more brown people than they were
and that's absolutely fantastic I have
full support and admiration for that
Trend but as that's happened at the same
time unrelated but at the same time we
have had an absolutely cataclysmic drop
off in genuine cognitive diversity the
range of views that you're allowed to
have the Overton wind window has shifted
left and tightened to a tiny little port
hole and if you haven't got your face in
that port hole then you're a bad person
and a lot of it is around this issue of
luxury views so for instance richy sunak
just been absolutely walloped by a lot
of his own party but certainly by um
most newspapers and most broadcasters
because um Rose bank has been given the
goahead that's the biggest untapped
field in the North Sea that we know of
uh and Rose bank is about 80 miles off
the shet off of Shetland It's relatively
accessible by North Sea standards and
now finally uh a UK listed company
Ithaca and the Norwegian State energy
giant equinor are going to develop that
field and it's got 300 million barrels
of oil at least right so that's enough
to keep the whole world going for three
days which doesn't sound a lot but but
it is Bri stand it's absolutely huge and
it's 8 I quids worth of investment is 2
and a half thousand jobs as the gmbb
union one of our main unions keeps
reminding the labor party labor Fame you
know in the typical fashion they they
don't agree with what the Tories are
doing on Rose bank because that will
upset their environmental Lobby uh but
they're not going to reverse it uh
because that would upset their
bluecollar you know gmbb Union lobby who
want those jobs for their for the for
their members but it makes complete
sense to me that we should be using our
own energy from the North Sea I mean why
because there's something within the
British uh establishment now called the
climate change committee that's the
government's own in-house a green
Watchdog that has statutory powers to
sort of push and go and chide ministers
if they're not doing everything that
they should be doing to get us to Net
Zero in 2050 even the climate change
committee admits that we will be using
oil and gas by the mid 2030s for 50% of
all our energy right even if Ren it's
currently 70 by by the way the climate
change committee says it will still be
50% of all our energy by mid 2030 and
that's if the climate change committee's
own estimates for the take up and
efficiency of Renewables the
improvements they're in are met and a
lot of people think they won't be met a
lot of people think they're far too Rosy
and too optimistic so we'll be lucky to
be at only 50% oil and gas by the mid
2030s it'll probably be higher and even
the climate change committee
they say that when we are at Net Zero in
2050 then we'll still be using oil and
gas for around 25% of all our energy so
if we're going to use oil and gas use
our own because it's cheaper it means we
get the jobs the tax revenue and the
prosperity and it's far less carbon
intensive what's the alternative the
alternative is you drill gas in Dakota
you put it through a pipeline to an LG
terminal in the States you you liquefy
fire it which is massively carbon and
energy intensive you put it in a tanker
that goes 3,200 Mi across the Atlantic
diesel powered by the way and then you
reg gasify at Milford Haven or somewhere
else in Mainland Europe all massively
energy intensive but at least we can
then tell ourselves oh this isn't our
carbon footprint but it is we have to be
smarter about this it makes huge sense
to use our own North Sea oil and gas
given that even under the most
panglossian the most uh Rosy assump
itions about our pathway towards Net
Zero by the climate change committee
itself we'll still be using an awful lot
of oil and gas for the rest of my life
so rather than just say as the Green
Party does this is morally obscene get
real you're going to need oil and gas at
least until 2050 probably for a lot
longer it's cheaper and it's more
environmentally friendly to use our own
but that's the thing is you're putting
forward a pragmatic
argument and and we don't don't do that
anymore because we just like nice little
sound bites that make us feel good yeah
that's true that's true I mean it's you
know economists have been the Dismal
scientists for years right I mean that
was uh originally a quote because
economists used to warn that um uh
because populations grow geometrically
but crops grow arithmetically that would
be subject to starvation of of course it
never happened because technology came
in and so
uh crops could also grow geometrically
not least with the Green Revolution and
pesticides fertilizer and all the rest
of it so man will find a way and I do
think we will find a way but I'm not
against for any moment the transition
away from from fossil fuels right I want
a cleaner country A Cleaner World for
for my kids and my grandkids it makes
sense to move away from fossil fuels you
know I'm a huge advocate advocate of
hydrogen I think hydrogen is a sort of
Cinderella uh but but we're now in a
point and this is this is one of the
upsides of the Gastly war in Ukraine
that you and I have talked about in the
past quite a lot Constantine one of the
upsides is that energy security is no
longer something that only sort of
spectrum nerds like me go on about right
is actually people come up to me in the
pub right and ask me about energy
security people come up to me in the pub
and ask me about OPEC these days and
that would never have happened two or
three years ago and I think what's
emerged from this war in Ukraine the
impact on Energy prices the impact on
the cost of living the fact that you
know people's house prices have fallen
they're feeling a lot less financially
secure than they were they're a lot more
worried about their their own future and
their children's
future what it has done it has allowed
to burst
through these kind of luxury views and
these lazy end of Empire assumptions
that what matters is you know your
feelings and you know your position in a
kind of social hierarchy of do goody
what's happening now those things are
being shifted away and we are suddenly
having a real conversation about Net
Zero how
much when for how long and who pays
right who pays now it was always Madness
to think you could possibly Implement
these massive changes without taking the
population with you now there's a sort
of do on B VI in the UK not from a lot
of our senior broadcasters that if they
say something it must be right and my
God why did you vote for brexit you
stupid plebs you should be dead you know
we've told you what to do and we get our
own way because we are the ruling class
there's still a lot of that in the UK
but now there's push back push back from
below and politicians who understand
that there's push back from below not
because people don't want to clean a
planet but because their white van on
their driveway
is their living it's their ability to
pay their kids lunch money to pay their
bills to keep a roof over their family's
head and if you're telling them that
they've got just got to junk that van
and buy a massively overpriced electric
van which will instantly fall in value
because the secondhand market for them
is terrible and you know if it goes
wrong you might as well buy new Vans
it's all about the battery you can't fix
it yourself then there is going to be
push back against that and we are now
seeing that push back but it's taken a a
war in Ukraine and some Gastly
geopolitics in order to Kickstart and
bring that debate about but at least
it's now happening Frances at least we
can now have a discussion and raise
issues about Net Zero not about the
ultimate direction of travel but the
speed and the cost and the distribution
of those costs we have to have those
discussions because if we don't have
those discussions this isn't a democracy
and if we don't have these discussions
we're never going to get there anyway
the whole cause will be solid because it
will just end up in Acron and ranker
because and it's such a great point
because no one's voted for this no one's
agreed to this out of the ordinary
populace it's been foed upon us and then
you go right well it would be a
controversial policy to introduce if the
economy was booming the fact that
everybody is struggling now and now
you're going to place this on top of
everyone I mean it's pretty much that's
that's a recipe for civil unrest if you
think about the now you know that and
const knows that and I know that but in
the aftermath of rishy sunak pushing the
ban on petrol and diesel cars back from
2030 to 2035 which is where it is across
practically the whole of the European
Union in the aftermath of that and in
the aftermath of sunak saying you know
what we really do need to do a bit of
drilling in the North Sea even though
there's still a 75% Winford tax on North
Sea profits you know you try you try
doing a complex Capital intensive
project in a hostile environment where
suddenly your profit the tax on your
profit goes from 30% to 75% in a few
months it's very very difficult but you
you and I in Constantine we know
instinctively that while there'll be
very vifer loud gobby critics of these
slight Retreats away from that zero we
know instinctively that an awful lot of
Silent people in the UK are going to go
yeah it sounds about right to me I'm
glad he's done that and so what's
happening now is that Rishi sunak after
a year in office where he's just been
fighting events he is now suddenly
belatedly finally starting to do some
politics and he's starting to do some
politics and his standings his racings
have actually gone up while he's been
doing this stuff over the last couple of
weeks even though the response from the
vast majority of the media particularly
the broadcast media where most people
get most of their news most of their
time still has been almost overwhel
whelmingly negative to the point of
being hysterical in some cases I like
the move away from fossil fuels right
but I've given you I think a very
coherent argument about why even people
that want the move away from fossil
fuels should understand that it makes
sense given those climate change
committee assumptions on our use of oil
and gas going forward for decades to
come to use our own well look mate
ultimately we we live in a democracy
right so the people have to be brought
along with it and they have to be asked
and they have to give their consent and
there's plenty of other issues on which
that isn't really happening thanks as
you say to the fact that there seems to
be a lock on certain issues in the way
that the mainstream has this
conversation and so I'm glad we're able
to have that Frank conversation here
which is one of the reasons I love doing
our show and having you on it do you
have a website or do you plan to have a
website because if you do then easy DNS
is a company for you easy DNS is the
perfect domain name regist our provider
and web host for you they have a track
record of standing up for their clients
whether it be cancel culture deplatform
attacks or overzealous government
agencies he knows about that so we you
in a second easy DNS have Rock Solid
Network infrastructure and fantastic
customer support they're in your corner
no matter what the world throws at you
unless it's your ex girlfriend in which
case you're on your own you know about
that move your domains and websites over
to to easydns right now all you've got
to do is go to easy
dns.com triggered that's easy
dns.com SLT triggered use our promo code
which is also triggered and get 50% off
the initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and
censorship there was one issue that you
mentioned which is a subject of your
last book uh which I think we should
spend a little time on because it's an
issue that affects almost everybody in
this country whether they own property
or not which is we have seen something
which you've actually been calling for
at least the end result which is for
house prices to slow down in terms of
Rise it's probably not happened the way
you would have wanted because it's not
happening because we're building more
houses what is the future of interest
rates and the housing market in this
country in your opinion well interest
rates in the UK the base rates currently
at
5.25% uh I think a lot of people assume
that's now the peak and the next move
will be down certainly a lot of mortgage
companies are now offering mortgages
5year fixes below 5% So Below where the
bank of England base rate is so that
means they must think the next move is
down and it's going to go quite a long
way further to compensate for the fact
um that they're offering a sub base rate
mortgage rate at the
moment I think that would be my central
assumption with the caveat that I
mentioned earlier if if OPEC plus wants
to turn the screw and put another all
price spike energy price spike upon us
even though the bank of England anything
it does with interest rates wouldn't
impact that at all the Optics of the
bank of England lowering interest rates
when inflation is going through the roof
for whatever reason is very very
difficult and they'll be seen to lose
credibility so we might yet see more
interest rate Rises courtesy of OPEC
plus I just put that out there but let's
assume that's not the case uh and assume
that interest rates are going to come
down um in the end we've still got
massive housing unaffordability in this
country yes prices have come off a
little bit but the average multiple to
buy a uh the average home in the UK is
still 8 to 10 times annual income right
when I bought my first property in the
mid 90s it was four to five times and
four to five times is sort of the
long-term historic average and that kind
of makes sense because if it's four to
five times you save like mad right and
then you get a mortgage on the income of
one of you for three three and a half
times and then your family chips in and
maybe the other person in a couple is
doing a bit of part-time work bit of
child care so you can get to four or
five times an ordinary family can buy an
ordinary house in an ordinary situation
but when it's nine or 10 times rising to
sort of 15 times in London and the
southeast and even more in some even not
particularly Swanky areas then it's
completely prohibitive right how can you
possibly how can two a professional
couple working full-time even before
child care they can only borrow six or
seven times there canbin salary I mean
it it's mad and that isn't going to
change just because we've seen house
prices come off a little bit because of
interest rate Rises we need to build
more homes now you kindly mention my my
book home truths the point of that book
was to highlight the fact that big
oligopolistic house builders massively
important house builders the top 10
house builders building about 70% of our
homes now they control
what gets built where and at what pace
they Hoover up most of the planning
commissions the problem isn't that there
isn't enough Planning Commission because
they're over a million planning
permissions outstanding held by these
big companies that don't use them
because they want to deliberately not
use them because they want to stop the
little builders that build quickly for
cash flow to from getting those they're
like OPC basically what you're saying
it's massive restrictive practices they
will deny it I mean that's why you I've
talked to Michael Gove a lot about this
uh and he's read my book very closely
I've spent a lot of time with him uh he
ended up in a speech calling the big
house builders quotes a cartel now this
is a public forum they deny that there's
no a prior evidence that they are that
because of course a cartel is illegal
but they are definitely an oligopoly
which is a small number of producers
deliberately restricting Supply the
House of Lords said that after an
extensive investigation back in
2016 and I think partly as a result of
the book and the speeches that go has
given
the competition and markets Authority is
now conducting an investigation into big
UK house builders to see if there are
restrictive practices now who knows what
they'll come up with our Regulators in
the UK you know that they could be quite
quite herbivorous at times a bit flabby
um I'm sure they'll come up with a kind
of oh it's the system it's no particular
oh very unfortunate lessons will need to
be learned I'm sure they won't get a
slap across the wrist but I think they
should because house building industry
is very good at drip feeding the market
generating contrived scarcity to keep
prices High to make more money building
fewer houses on much bigger margins you
know a lot of house builders they got
margins of 15 20 even 25 and 30% right
they they they're using basically
Victorian technology you know this isn't
rocket science look I come from a long
line of Irish Builders right there's a
big difference between a good Builder
and a not good Builder there's a lot of
skill in building a home right but it's
a not uncommon skill it's everywhere
it's not like you're a tech company
that's invented something so why are you
getting 75 million quid annual bonuses
among housing Executives why because
there are restrictive practices
happening because there isn't any real
competition happening because the house
building industry isn't responding to
massive unmet Supply by building more to
keep prices relatively stable they're
deliberately building less and that is a
big big problem given that for the vast
majority of people buying a home will be
the biggest purchase that they ever make
isn't that just corruption ly corruption
is a difficult word I I you know I I've
said and I'll say again and I'll say
again that they deny it I mean the whole
animous of of my book home truths is
that there are restrictive practices
going on in the UK building
industry um uh and it's up to Regulators
to try and eat those out it's it's very
difficult it's very complicated but how
else can you explain these massive
margins how else can you explain the
fact that we build so few homes these
days you we haven't built a new town a
new settlement in the UK in my lifetime
and I'm in my early 50s the last one was
Milton keing and yet during that period
we've gone from 45 million to almost 70
million people that's insane the UK now
has 420 homes per thousand right in
France it's
550 in Germany it's 580 that makes a
huge difference and it's not even
immigration a lot of people say it's
immigration France has had more
immigration per than we've had right but
they've just built a lot more homes and
it's not even because France is bigger
than us we use 2% of our entire land at
the moment for residential housing plus
Gardens 2% the green belt the sacred
green belt 133% and far from getting
concreted over as endless lib Dems keep
telling us the green belt is actually
now more than twice the size in terms of
acreage as it was in the late 1970s
because councils keep adding to it but
in the end we have to give young people
the chance the chance that that my
generation had the Dignity of owning
their own home buying their own own own
home this is now seriously messing with
our demography oh mess people are not
having kids cuz they're still living in
shared houses into their early 30s right
pass that now pass that now and Liam So
reading between the lines there if I'm
an ordinary person looking to buy or
sell a house or whatever interest rates
are likely to perhaps you know with the
OPEC exception likely to drift down wait
I would wait they're likely to drift
down at the same time we're not going to
due to this oligopoly be building way
more houses than we have been
consistently so that tells me that house
prices are going to go back up well I
think house prices they won't go back up
a lot until interest rates come down a
lot because what really drives the house
pric is the purchasing power of people
on the demand side I mean maybe the
government will do something really
stupid like another raft have helped to
buy which has been an absolutely
terrible scheme it's been good for some
of the people who are on it but for the
rest of the people the vast majority you
can't access it it's just pushed up
prices given that it hasn't really led
to more Supply a lot of houses built
under help to buy you could only get it
for new builds initially were
substandard uh a lot of them didn't have
you know fire um protection in the
cavity walls and so on it basically
Consolidated even more the position of
the big Builders because the big
Builders hoovered up most helped to buy
the government might do some more help
to buy if they're particularly stupid
because it's a nice cheap easy quick
headline but aside from that I don't
think house prices are going to spike up
quickly because there is a nervousness
about interest rates inflation and I
think that nervousness will be with us
for a number of years even if the
headline numbers start to improve but if
you are going to fix your home loan as
of now uh late September 2023 I would
wait because I do think aside from the
OPEC whizbang which I mentioned earlier
I do think the high probability is that
interest rates will come down I don't
think we're going to see ultra low you
know half a percent 1% one and a half
percent as we did after the Layman
crisis and then all those less years of
quantitative easing but I don't see any
reason why we can't get back down to
sort of three 4% and if you can fix a
loan for five years at 3 or 4% rather
than four and a half or 5% it makes an
enormous difference to your family's
finances Lim moving on now to the last
part of the interview are you hopeful
for the future economically I am because
and I'm hopeful for the UK and I'm
hopeful for the global economy even
though when I compare now to when I sort
of came of age economically in the fall
of the Bing wall and going to live in
former Soviet Union and Eastern Europe
during the early 90s the sort of Madness
of the France's fukuyama dictat it's the
end of history and people like me saying
no it's history on speed if you've been
to Eastern Europe they're going through
like generational changes in four weeks
right but what was fukuyama saying he
was saying it's a unipolar world now and
as you said earlier Constantine it isn't
a unipolar world it's a multi-polar
world because that is the his isic Norm
a multi-polar world um but Liam hold on
just to challenge you on that I think to
say that it's a historic Norm is true
but that's because the technological
level of connection between the world
was different it was much more difficult
you know the Chinese Empire in the 8
Century couldn't dominate the world sure
that's true in a way that so just
distance Made It by definition
multi-polar right because you couldn't
challenge all so guess here we are at
the height of technology and we're
becoming more multi-polar right we're
moving away from the unar so so it's not
necessar the relationship is complex
right the relationship is complex so am
I optimistic I am optimistic because I
believe in the power of technology and
Innovation and human
endeavor uh and even though being a
journalist makes you kind of hard-nosed
and cynical I mean most people I meet in
the world and interact with are good
people and they want to do well I think
this country in particular has not just
the germ it has a kind of in its
bloodstream it has real entrepreneurial
genius and Vim in this country and it's
partly I think because of the big influx
of immigrants that we've had over many
years and know your family a Latin
American got Slavic guy here you know
some Patty from way back but but we all
feel that we're Brits right and a lot of
Brits have these different identities
and that gives them that kind of
entrepreneurial Edge we create lots and
lots of businesses the world still wants
to invest in us we still get a huge line
share of all the foreign direct
investment coming into Europe you know
we've still got the vast bulk of the
world-class universities in Europe in
this country it's easy to carp and it's
easy to say things are wrong and it's
for people like us with platforms to
constantly you know criticize and to
prod and to poke and to test and to
question right this is what we do it's
why people want to hear what we've got
to
say because that leads to progress but
you also have to occasionally step back
and say in the face of people who are
constantly negative the whole time in
order to make themselves sound good in
their own eyes you have to push back and
say well look where the UK is compared
to other countries at this point and
look where the UK is compared to 20 or
30 years ago and on most fronts even in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
there's never been a better time to be
alive now I know you we've been through
a lot in this country we've been through
all the political turmoil the
independence referendum and brexit then
you know the Fiasco that was locked down
and then the this war in Ukraine which
has obviously been really really
stressful and we and we're you know
thousands of miles from Ukraine it
sounds ridiculous given that people
actually dying and and and genuinely
suffering but economically the war in
Ukraine has been very testing for us and
I think it could easily get more so but
I I still remain optimistic because I
think we are an entrepreneurial country
I think there's a lot of vim and vigor
here and in the end you know unless
you're optimistic you might as well not
get out of bed yeah uh Liam we've talked
purely about economics which is
fascinating as always I just before we
let you go a quick political question
which is we obviously have an election
coming up uh next year uh how do you see
things going as they are at the moment
well as it they are at the moment you'd
have to be a brave man to bet against
certainly labor as the biggest party if
not with a a full majority I think
that's a much bigger assumption but a
week's a long time in politics and we're
still still months away from this
election and so you know the Tories
could yet turn it round and and surprise
people I mean I'm not saying that's the
most likely outcome but I don't think
it's a very unlikely outcome it could
happen uh I think the S SMP are going to
get whacked I think they've really
suffered as a result of the way Nicholas
sturgeon left office in a very kind of
disorderly manner I don't think their
current leader is particularly
impressive with all respect to him on
the contrary I think Labour's leader in
Scotland an Asawa is a pretty impressive
guy and he's certainly making a Headway
but I think the Tories could yet salvage
some kind of comeback enough at least to
make labor not the biggest party or even
we could have a 1974 situation where you
have two elections in succession I think
it genuinely could be that close but as
always with politics it depends on the
econ economy stupid as you know
Clinton's right man James Carville said
back in the day if they can turn the
economy around if they can get inflation
down if they can get a Feelgood Factor
going if they can get some young people
on the housing ladder if they can start
building some social housing something
that we haven't said that's the way to
unlock the red wall start building some
social housing so people can be more
assured that their kids are going to
have a roof over their head um if
they're from a low-income background
then I think the Tories could yet pull
off a surprise that's an outside bet the
odds are long but I'm just putting it
out there as a possibility well Liam
it's such a pleasure having you back on
which is why I'm really looking forward
to what our audience want to ask of you
on our local sections before we head
over to locals though as you know our
last question is always the same which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that really should be I
think we should be talking a lot more
economically about the Pacific Rim the
Pacific Rim is the fastest growing area
of the economy in in in the world the UK
as you know has just joined the cptpp
that's the com brand R hensive and
Progressive trans-pacific partnership a
big trading block uh I think it's a
great achievement that we've uh joined
that block um and yet people don't
really understand the economic power of
that block I think the government should
be talking more about that we should be
encouraging more of our people to export
out there work out there live out there
the Brits have got a great track record
in different historic circumstances of
living and working and driving economies
in different parts of the world and we
should continue to do that because we're
good at that because you know you've got
the the language that's spoken
everywhere the rule of law the way we
structure contracts the reputation of
our universities the extent to which our
sort of popular culture is loved you
know the Premier League comedy all the
rest of it we should be making use of
that and we should be trying to
encourage our young people to make their
way
overseas building their own Futures
particularly around that Pacific Rim
because that is now the economic center
of gravity of the world not the states
Liam haran thank you so much follow us
over to locals where we ask cam your
question and also chip in a few are our
own see you
there what should the UK be doing to
take advantage of the opportunities
presented by leaving the
EU